>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Stephanie Marcus:
Good morning.
I'm Stephanie Marcus from
the science, technology
and business division, and
we host this lecture series
with NASA Goddard 12 years now.
So it's really awesome.
We've had some wonderful
programs, and you're welcome
to catch the old
ones on our website.
We have them all up there,
and they are quite
a range of topics.
We try to do both space
sciences and earth sciences,
and sometimes we had a
harder time getting the earth
science people.
So we had our hydrology
person recently,
and today we have our atmosphere
person, and I think all
of us get very upset if GPS
isn't working, or our computers
or whatever depends on
satellites and things,
where the weather in the upper
atmosphere can really give us a
hard time.
So today we're going
to hear about that.
NASA has two new missions
to study the ionosphere,
upper atmosphere, and
we're very lucky today
to have Dr. Sarah Jones
from Goddard speak to us.
I'm not going to try to say
what she's going to talk about,
because I have trouble
understanding it.
I thought I knew the air,
and space, and all that,
but there's a lot more to it.
Doctor Jones is from Vermont,
and she did her physics
studies at Dartmouth.
I see my former supervisor
Connie is here.
She's from New Hampshire, so she
was really wanting to hear this,
and also, she got
her PhD in physics
from the University
of New Hampshire.
So I'm not going to
say anything more.
Let's hear about up there.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Sarah Jones: Thanks
very much, Stephanie,
and thanks for inviting me here
at the Library of Congress.
I think this is an awesome
series of lectures here.
At NASA, we get really excited
to come out and tell people
about the great work
that we're doing.
At least we think it's great,
and hopefully you will, too.
So today, we're going to
talk about the science
of the upper atmosphere,
by which I mean essentially
the boundary
between Earth and space.
And so the atmosphere that we
breathe here below thins out
and kind of goes out into
the vastness of space,
and we're going to
talk about this region
where the particles are
getting really thin,
and some of them are charged.
Stephanie mentioned the
ionosphere, and this is a region
that is going to be studied
by two new NASA missions
called Gold and Icon.
So NASA divides its science
into four different categories.
There's a lot of
overlap between them.
There's astrophysics, earth
science, planetary science,
and heliophysics, where I work,
which is basically a study
of the sun itself and then
the effects of the sun
on everything else -- the Earth,
the rest of the solar system.
And so we're studying in my
group the upper atmosphere
and the effects of the
sun on the atmosphere,
which can be considered
space weather.
Now in heliophysics,
we have a whole fleet
of missions studying
different pieces
of the scientific puzzle all
throughout what's called the
heliosphere, which
is this region
of the universe that's
affected directly by the sun.
We have the Voyager
satellites that are basically
at that very boundary, the
edge of the sun's influence
over the universe,
and it's color-coded,
where the orange missions
are missions that are
in implementation, which means
they've either just launched
and they're going through
their commissioning phase,
or they're going to launch soon,
and so I wanted to pause here
and give a shout out to
the Parker Solar Probe,
which here is called
Solar Probe Plus.
It's been renamed
after Eugene Parker,
who's a famous solar physicist,
and some of you may
have got this handout
which NASA is calling solar
pizza, and it tells you
about how Parker Solar Probe
is going to be the mission
that comes closer to the
sun than ever before,
basically touching the sun.
So if you think about
the sun being --
let's say if it was 75
feet away from the Earth.
Parker Solar Probe would be
three feet away from the sun.
It's really close to the sun,
and it's about 2,500
degrees Fahrenheit
where it will be coming
closest to the sun,
and so this is a mission that's
been dreamed about for decades,
and we haven't been able to do
it, because that's really hot,
and the satellite would
have melted, but by now,
engineering technology
has come to the point
where materials could
be developed to shield
that spacecraft so that
it won't be destroyed.
So that launches
at the end of July,
and my colleague Doctor Alex
Young will be here in December
to talk to you all about
Parker Solar Probe.
Today we're going to
talk about Gold and Icon.
Gold is a mission that consists
of a camera that's
called a hosted payload,
because it's actually
riding on a satellite
that is not a government
satellite.
It's owned by a commercial
company,
and so we're renting
a space and a downlink
for data from this satellite.
It's something new that NASA
hasn't really done before,
and it's a way to get your
instruments into space
and spend less money doing
it, especially if you're going
to a place like geostationary
orbit, where Gold had to go
to make its measurements.
So Gold launched in January,
January 24th of this year.
The satellite is operated
by SES Government Solutions.
It's called SES-14.
You can look it up on
the internet if you'd
like more information,
and since then,
the satellite has been
slowly making its way
up to what we call
geostationary orbit,
which is a location 22,000
miles above the Earth,
and it will park there and sit
there while the Gold camera
looks down at the Earth
and takes pictures
of what's going on below.
This mission is led by
University of Central Florida,
and the principal
investigator is Dr. Richard East
at the Laboratory
for Atmospheric
and Space Physics in Colorado.
The other new mission to study
the upper atmosphere is called
ICON, Ionospheric Connection
Explorer, and it launches
in one week, next Thursday,
and it's going to launch
into low Earth orbit,
which is the type of orbit
that the International
Space Station is in,
so it will be flying
directly through this region
of the upper atmosphere that
we'll be talking about today,
and it's going to study --
essentially, its
primary mission is
to study how this
region changes,
this upper atmosphere
changes, in response to weather
that we're experiencing
down below.
So this is a picture
of the atmosphere.
This is the stratosphere, right.
This is where our airplanes
fly and where we have clouds,
and then it fades out
into the upper atmosphere
that I'm talking about, and
the region we're talking
about today starts
about 60 miles above us
and then extends
outward into space.
So it's essentially the boundary
between Earth and space,
and you can think of the gas
up here as just an extension
of the air that we
breathe below.
It consists of oxygen, nitrogen,
different types of gas.
It's much thinner
than it is here below.
Think of going up
to Mount Everest.
The air gets pretty thin, right?
At 60 miles, it's a whole
lot thinner, and it moves.
It has temperature.
The gas has temperature
and responds to pressure,
and there's a wind up
there, just like there is
down here below, and so we see
changes on long-term scales,
weeks and months, which are like
climate type changes down here,
and we also see changes on
the order of hours or days,
more like the weather patterns
that we see down here below.
Now most of the gas up
there is like the air
that we breathe below.
However, when the
sunlight comes down
and bombards the atmosphere,
some of that neutral gas gets
ripped apart into electrons
and ions and it becomes
electrically charged,
and so these ions,
this small population
of ions is appropriately
named the ionosphere,
and the ionosphere and the
neutral upper atmosphere are
in the same region of
space, this 60-ish miles
above our heads,
interacting with each other.
And this breaking apart of
the gas that's up there is one
of the ways, actually, that
the atmosphere protects us
from getting too much UV light.
So I wanted to show a video,
an animation that was created
by NASA to take us on a
tour of the ionosphere.
[ Music ]
>> Wanting for more space,
open skies, and exotic travel?
Then look up, about 30
to 60 miles straight up,
at the ionosphere,
Earth's interface to space.
Nestled far above the clouds
but below outer space,
this little-understood
destination invites you
to explore its many features.
Experience both the
weather from Earth
and the weather from space.
Marvel at the ballet of radio
waves and navigation signals,
like GPS, leaping through
this particle paradise.
Sit back, relax, and take in
the aurora, some satellites, --
-- and the International
Space Station as they sail by,
and you'll want your
camera handy for one
of the region's signature
features,
bright and colorful air glow.
This daily show is made possible
by the ionosphere's own
swarming charged particles,
because that's what
the ionosphere is.
It's all charged particles.
During the day, enjoy the sea
of particles freshly
energized by the sun.
As the sun sets, this
particle party relaxes
and the air glow thins.
Our quieter night life lets
you gaze into clear skies.
The ionosphere is
in constant motion,
an amazing effect
of space weather.
Don't miss when solar
storms rain down.
The storm separates the
particles even more,
making this colorful region
delightfully more dense
in some places and
stunningly sparse in others.
And don't forget about
storms from Earth below.
Your weather from back
home also stirs up this one
of a kind destination.
Experience the unique
beauty of every season,
as changes in Earth's
atmosphere daily
and annually can
create pressure waves,
changing the ionosphere's
shape and density.
Venture to the equator,
where ion particles are
packed in lush and thick.
Cruise along a magnetic
field line
and see how the ionosphere's
charged material also interacts
with Earth's own magnetic field.
Don't miss the superhighway of
particles zipping out to space
and back down to the planet.
This unpredictable array
of charged particles can
help you unplug and unwind.
This is because the crowd of
particles can garble the radio
and satellite communications
from home.
The ionosphere welcomes
you to discover more
about this little-known region.
After all, once you've explored
this interface to space,
who knows how much farther
you'll be able to go?
[ Music ]
[ Beeping Sound ]
>> Sarah Jones: So you saw
in the video a little bit
about how dynamic
the ionosphere is.
Because those particles are
charged, they respond directly
to magnetic and electric fields
that are in the atmosphere
and are moved around by them,
and so you can get changes
in the very shape of the
ionosphere on a time scale
of hours, and then you
have longer term changes,
like annual changes, that
were mentioned in the video.
Now the ionosphere is also the
region where radio waves have
to propagate through from
our satellites to the ground
for things like GPS, and we use
it for other purposes as well.
For example, when you're doing
long-range communications
from the ground, your AM radio
station can send your signals up
and actually bounce them
off of the ionosphere
to send the signal further than
it would have gone otherwise.
But when we get dynamic
space weather, as it's called
when the radiation from
the sun is changing,
it's becoming more intense,
there are things
called storms happening,
there can be structures
in the ionosphere
that can then garble
the signals.
[ Music ]
Oh, I'm sorry.
We don't need to see that again.
And so the ionosphere can
actually cause problems
with long-range communications
via radio waves,
and it can also garble some
signals from satellites --
for example, GPS -- and then
that can cause usually very
small errors in GPS locations,
which are important more
for technologies that are
on the horizon, like
self-driving cars, but also,
GPS is being used for some
creative applications,
like sending out
plough trucks unmanned
so that they can clear ice and
snow off of dangerous roads,
or also for agricultural
purposes,
so that you can have
unmanned vehicles
that are gathering crops,
and so this is important
for those types of applications.
In addition to that,
the charging
of the atmosphere has effects
on power lines down below.
It causes what's called
geomagnetically induced
currents, which usually
aren't a problem,
but in rare cases can actually
do some damage to transformers,
and so power companies are
really interested in learning
about this process so that they
can better protect their assets
and prevent problems.
So these are some of the
reasons why it's important
to understand the ionosphere.
It's also important
to understand the neutral
part of the atmosphere.
Remember that's the
bulk of the particles,
and your satellites
are flying through,
ploughing through these
particles as they move
through low Earth
orbit like Icon will,
like the International Space
Station does, and if you think
about driving a car,
right, ideally,
you want a very aerodynamic
design for your car,
because whether you can see
it or not, you're driving
through the air, and you want it
to be deflected around your car.
If you have a boxy car,
you're going to use more gas.
It's going to pull
back on your car.
Well, the same thing happens
with satellites in space.
The air is much thinner, but it
still pulls on the satellite,
and what that does to a
satellite is over time,
the satellite actually loses a
little bit of altitude steadily,
and you either have to use
some sort of act of propulsion
to bump it back up like they do
on the International Space
Station, or eventually,
it gets to a low enough altitude
where it actually re-enters the
Earth's atmosphere and burns up.
Most of it burns up.
And there is a recent example
I don't know if any of you saw
of a Chinese space station
that was re-entering
the Earth's atmosphere.
Most of it did burn up,
and then pieces of it fell
into the Pacific Ocean.
But understanding when and
where these satellites are going
to go requires knowing
the density of the gas
up in the upper atmosphere,
how much is there,
what is the composition
of the gas,
and there was a well-publicized
event in 1979, when Skylab,
which was the American space
station, re-entered much earlier
than had originally
been predicted.
It was predicted
before it happened.
The engineers were updating
their predictions over time,
but it was earlier than
their initial prediction,
because during the time
that Skylab was up,
the sun was actually putting
out a lot more radiation
than anyone had expected,
and when that happens,
the atmosphere receives all
this energy and gets heated,
and the particles
actually expand,
and so you get gas
coming from down below.
Now it's up at a
higher altitude.
Now you have a lot more
gas that you're having
to move the satellite through,
and it loses orbit faster.
And so I don't know
if anyone knows this,
but as I was reading this
article from CBS News,
I found out that when
Skylab did come down,
pieces of it came
down in Australia.
The Australian government fined
the US 400 Australian dollars
for littering.
[ Laughter ]
And apparently, we still
haven't paid it, but --
[ Laughter ]
Okay, and so this is
one important reason
for just knowing how much gas
is there and when is it going
to be more dense
than it was before,
how is this region responding
to the sun's radiation,
which then also requires
a better understanding
of what the sun is putting out,
which is why we need
missions like Parker.
Another reason, though, is
that we're not just
tracking satellites.
At this point, there's a lot
of debris orbiting in space.
One example is a problem
that happened in 2009.
Two satellites crashed into
each other and smashing
into little pieces,
and there was a bit
of a concern for a while.
Engineers went and rushed to
make the calculations to see
if there was a chance that
the debris would come near the
International Space Station,
because when debris strikes the
space station or a satellite,
it can do damage, or in that
case, even endanger the lives
of the astronauts, and
fortunately, in this case,
it was okay, but making those
predictions is really dependent
on knowing the shape and
the density of the gas
in that upper atmosphere.
And so we really do need to know
both how the ionosphere works,
and how the neutral atmosphere
works, and how they push on
and change each other so that
we can understand what we need
to know for our technologies,
and one way that we can measure
what's going on up there is
to measure actually the glow
that comes from these particles.
They would be invisible, except
there's a process called airglow
which makes it so that we can
take pictures of the shape
of the upper atmosphere,
pictures of the shape
of the boundary between
Earth and space,
and I have another video for
you, the last video, fortunately
or unfortunately, and
it's going to talk
to you a little bit
more about air glow.
>> The night sky is
never truly dark.
If you removed light pollution,
the moon, stars, and galaxies,
there would still be --
-- a very faint, colorful glow.
That's airglow.
With cameras, you can
photograph it only
on the darkest of nights.
It's about one-tenth as bright
as the combined light
of all the stars.
From above, it forms a luminous
bubble encapsulating Earth.
Appearing right at the interface
to space, airglow holds clues
to how our atmosphere
affects weather and space
and how space weather
affects humans on Earth.
The balance of light
spans 60 to 400 miles
above the Earth's surface.
In the uppermost boundary of the
atmosphere is the ionosphere.
This is where our GPS
signals and astronauts travel.
What makes this region
complicated is
that it's constantly changing.
It reacts to both energy
emanating from the sun
and weather near
Earth's surface,
and as the ionosphere
fluctuates, so can conditions
in near Earth space, where
the space station lies.
But spotting changes in
the ionosphere is a lot
like trying to watch the wind.
You need a marker of some kind
to see the invisible
particles move past,
and for that, we have airglow.
>> Sarah Jones: So you just
saw some pictures of airglow.
You can see how it looks
pretty structured sometimes.
In addition to breaking apart
neutral gas in the atmosphere,
when sunlight hits
the atmosphere,
it also causes the ions
of the ionosphere as well
as the neutral gas
to give off light.
It glows in a variety
of different colors all
across the spectrum of
light, from near infrared,
through visible light, up into
the ultraviolet, which is light
that we can't see
with our human eyes,
and it's a really useful tool
for us in studying this region,
because actually, by measuring
the light that's coming off
of the atmosphere,
you can determine
to some extent the
composition of the atmosphere,
because different
types of gas --
for example, oxygen
and nitrogen --
will give off different
colors of airglow.
Also, in terms of measuring
density and temperature,
you can calculate that from
measurements of how bright
to air glow is, and you
can even measure the motion
of the particles from
Doppler shifts in the light
that you're measuring.
So it's an extremely
powerful tool
for understanding this region,
and this region, this transition
between the Earth's
atmosphere and space,
it's really interesting,
because you've got these ionized
particles moving in response to
magnetic and electric fields,
and then you've got the ions
and the neutrals both moving
in response to pressure
gradients
and temperature differences,
much like the weather fronts
that we have here, down
in the lower atmosphere.
And so the neutral
gas responding mostly
to the pressure and temperature
has itself a temperature
of about 1,000 degrees
Fahrenheit.
It's pretty hot.
The ions, actually,
the ionosphere has a temperature
that's a bit hotter than that,
and if we could be transported
and we could take a trip
up to the ionosphere, we would
actually feel a really strange
sensation of having
two winds at once,
two different temperatures,
two different directions,
one denser than the other.
It's trying to restart again.
Sorry.
>> The night --
>> Okay. All right.
So for a long time,
scientists thought
that this upper atmosphere
responded primarily
to what's coming at us
from the sun and that
that was pretty much
the only impact,
and it certainly
does have an impact.
When extreme ultraviolet
light comes from the sun
into the atmosphere, it
heats up different parts
of the atmosphere, in particular
the stratosphere down below,
which can then cause what
are called atmospheric tides
in the air, similar to the tides
that we have in the ocean water,
and so it's an effect
coming from below,
but it's indirectly caused by
the sun, because it's a result
of the heating from the
sun's light coming down.
And in addition to
those types of effects
which cause different
large-scale features
in the ionosphere, the sun
also gives off a steady stream
of radiation and magnetic
field called the solar wind,
and sometimes can give off
more of a burst of radiation --
for example, when we have
coronal mass ejections.
Has anyone heard of those?
The coronal mass ejection is
when a sun essentially
spits off a piece of itself,
and it goes hurtling outward,
sometimes toward the Earth,
and it contains solar
plasma and magnetic fields
that then interact with
the Earth's magnetic field
and the Earth's upper
atmosphere,
and this causes effects
which we call space weather,
and some of them are
storms typically referred
to as geomagnetic storms, and
they can cause large-scale,
global-scale heating of the
atmosphere which will, again,
then lift those particles
to higher altitudes,
where they will more
likely interact
with satellites in
low Earth orbit.
And so for a long time,
scientists thought this was
pretty much the complete
picture, but recently, in
addition to the space weather
that you get coming from the
sun, there's been a growing body
of evidence that
shows that it seems
like certain weather events
from below are actually showing
up in the upper atmosphere.
Now this is a picture of airglow
where you see the whole half
of the Earth in airglow,
taken from the moon in 1972.
The Apollo 16 mission
had a camera on the moon
where they could image
the Earth and the airglow.
I think it looks
kind of like a mouse.
And so the bright
half there is the half
of the Earth that's getting
hit directly by sunlight,
and so the airglow is
the brightest there.
That tail of the mouse
at the bottom is
actually the auroral oval,
where you're getting
the Northern Lights,
and there would be one --
and the Southern Lights,
so there should be
one on both sides.
You can't see the other
one because it's swamped
by the airglow emissions,
but on the night side,
the mouse has some
little arms coming out.
This is a feature that
was discovered in the 40s
by a scientist named Appleton.
It's called the Appleton
anomaly, although it's not
so much as anomaly now
because it's been explained,
and we're not getting into it
because it's kind
of complicated.
I just wanted to point out that
the mouse's arms look pretty
smooth, but recently, we've had
cameras with higher resolution
that have gone through
and measured the Earth
in the same way -- for
example, the image satellite --
and we've been able to
build up pictures like this,
where those arms of the
mouse are actually bands
that go all the way around the
Earth, and they're not smooth
like scientists thought.
There's actually a sort of
bead type structure there
where you have bright
spots along the arcs,
and this is an image
that it's in a paper
by Doctor Thomas
Immel, who's the PI,
the principal investigator,
of the Icon mission.
He's leading that mission,
and he shows evidence
that these bright
spots correspond
to weather that's happening
below in the tropics,
and so this and other evidence
that's similar was part
of the motivation
for the Icon mission.
Icon is designed to study
really this brand-new area
of scientific research, right.
It's like for a long time,
scientists have been saying,
"Well, just ignore
what's happening below
because it doesn't
affect anything,"
and now there's evidence
saying, "Hang on.
You shouldn't have ignored
that," so NASA's going back,
and we're not going to
ignore that anymore.
We're going to start
measuring what's happening
in the upper atmosphere in
response to the weather below.
So ICON has four instruments.
So the satellite will be
orbiting in low Earth orbit,
actually flying through this
airglow that you're seeing,
and on the horizon, it's going
to take pictures of the airglow
in infrared, visible light,
and far ultraviolet light,
and from those measurements,
it can get the temperature,
it can get a measure
of the winds
where the neutral particles are
moving, and it can get a measure
of the composition and
how many ions are there.
And in addition, they have
another instrument that's called
an NC2 instrument.
It takes measurements
right there locally.
It's an ion velocity meter
that gathers up the particles
and measures them to determine
the drift of the ions,
so you're getting
the second wind.
You're measuring both the
wind of the neutral particles
and the ionized particles, and
it's also giving information
about the electric
fields in that area.
So additional evidence that
the weather below is actually
affecting the upper atmosphere.
There's a computer simulation
done by Astrid Maute,
who's also a part of the ICON
mission, where she showed
that during El Nino, when
the ocean water is warmer,
it causes more water
vapor to be released,
and that sets off a chain
reaction that can push --
-- the lower border of
the ionosphere upwards
and actually change the shape
of that boundary, and again,
that moves the particles
up to a higher altitude.
And so in her computer
simulation,
this plot on the right
shows the density
of the ionosphere during
one of these events,
and you have longitude on
the x-axis and latitude
on the y-axis, and you can see
that because particles were
lifted up in certain areas,
the ionosphere is
more dense there.
Particles from below came up
and increased the density.
So that's one way that El
Nino could affect the upper
atmosphere, and now
ICON has to go and see
if they can measure that.
They'll be flying right
through regions like this
that are expected to
have higher density.
But one of the coolest
things that we want
to measure is gravity
waves, not to be confused
with gravitational waves, which
are the warps in space-time
that won the Nobel
Prize in 2017,
but still interesting
nonetheless.
These are buoyancy waves.
If you think of water
flowing over a rock,
you get ripples in the water.
The same thing happens with air.
Air flowing over mountain ranges
will be rippled, and also,
in this case, this is
a computer simulation
of what the upper atmosphere
would look like after a tsunami.
The tsunami is a large storm,
and the cyclone actually sets
up this ripple structure in the
air, and so this is the type
of measurement that ICON
and Gold will be making.
ICON will be flying through
those ripples, right,
but Gold will be sitting 22,000
miles above, looking down,
getting this whole big picture,
and so when ICON says, "Well,
we've seen some ripples,
but we have no idea
where they're from," Gold
can look and say, "Well,
we see there's a
big storm near you,
and that's where
they're coming from,"
and it gives us the complete
picture of what's going on.
So you can think of Gold as like
your typical weather satellite,
only it's looking at the
upper atmosphere instead
of the lower atmosphere, and
you can think of ICON as sort
of the hurricane chasers going
into the eye of the storm.
And so as I mentioned,
Gold launched in January.
It's going to give us
these images much faster
than we've ever had before,
once every half-hour,
which might seem kind of slow
compared to what we're used to,
but what we've had
in the past was more
like one per several hours
or even one per day
or several days.
So this will allow us to
have enough resolution
to measure what would be
considered weather effects
rather than long-term
climate type effects,
like we measured in the past.
So this video just shows
the viewing geometries
of the GOLD and ICON missions.
Gold is actually hovering
over a fixed location,
so it's rotating with the Earth.
It's hovering over the
mouth of the Amazon River,
and ICON is cutting through
in the atmosphere below.
It whips around at a rate of
about one orbit per 90 minutes,
an hour and a half,
and GOLD has a camera
that actually has a
split field of view.
So it takes a picture, then
it moves over a little bit,
takes another picture, and so on
across the northern hemisphere.
Then you'll see it go back
across the southern hemisphere,
and it builds up a complete,
essentially mosaic image
of what's going on below.
And those little triangles
coming out from ICON,
those are the fields of view of
the different airglow cameras
that they have on board.
And once GOLD gets done
scanning across the Earth,
it actually goes back
and scans the horizon,
which is where ICON is
looking from down below.
It gives a different
type of science.
And so this color scale here is
what the ionosphere will look
like when it's being measured.
Gold actually will
be measuring night
from the neutral particles,
so it will look a
little bit different,
but it also changes
from day to day.
And so the airglow gives
you a sort of modeled look
that corresponds to the shape
of the atmosphere, the density,
what kind of particles are
there, and it allows you
to get most of the information
that you would need for any sort
of computer simulation
that you're using.
Other information will
come from missions
like Parker Solar Probe, where
you're getting information
about what's coming
from the sun,
and this will help us move
toward first being able
to understand what's
going on now, right.
That's what we call
now-casting, and then over time,
being able to start
forecasting and saying, "Look,
this is what's happening
at the sun,
and so we can expect this sort
of effect in the atmosphere,
which might have this sort of
effect on our technologies."
And so that's where
we're heading.
Gold and Icon won't get
us all the way there.
It's the very beginning
of forecasting weather
down here on Earth.
But they're a big step
in the right direction
that will help us
understand and try to tease
out the different effects of
what's happening at the sun
versus what's coming up from
down below -- tsunamis, El Nino,
other weather patterns
like that.
And so before I go, I
wanted to invite you
to watch the icon launch on NASA
TV, and so this is a picture
over here of the fairing
that icon will go into.
They just did their
mission readiness review,
I saw on the NASA
blog yesterday,
so they're moving
forward toward launch,
and launch is next
Thursday, which is June 14th,
and it will be -- the
coverage will start
at 9:45 a.m. eastern time.
The launch will more likely be
around 10:00 a.m., and that,
you can watch it on NASA
TV on your TV station,
or you can watch it
streaming on the internet.
And so we're very excited
for this, and I just want
to thank you all again
for coming and listening.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephanie Marcus:
Thank you so much.
I guess one of these days,
we'll have the space weather
girl who's also giving
that forecast along with
the Earth weather girl.
We'll take questions now, and
Dr. Jones will repeat them
so everyone can hear them.
>> Your mission in
the ionosphere,
it appeared there were two
winds, potentially funny.
Have they shown any
indication of some type
of whirlpool configuration
that we see
in rivers occurring
in the ionosphere?
>> Sarah Jones: So
the question was
about the two different
winds that are happening
in the upper atmosphere, the
ion wind and the neutral wind,
and whether or not we see
whirlpool type effects.
Actually, there are all kinds
of really interesting effects,
not exactly the same,
but happening
in the upper atmosphere.
For example, those two arms of
the mouse, the bands that are
around the Earth,
they're really symmetrical
around the Earth's
magnetic equator,
and they actually are caused by
what's called a fountain effect,
which occurs because
of the Earth's magnetic
and electric fields pulling on
those ions, and it causes them
to move upward and
then outward and down,
kind of like a fountain,
and that's what produces the
light in those two bands.
There are also other patterns
that I'm not very familiar with,
but one called the winter polar
vortex, which also moves air
from the polar regions
down toward the equator.
So yeah, there are a lot of
similarities like the two.
>> What are the effects
of the El Nino thickening
of the ionosphere on Earth?
>> Sarah Jones: So the
thickening of the ionosphere,
it could potentially cause
effects like small changes
in the accuracy of GPS or issues
for long-range communications.
Ultimately, the big effect, I
think, would be on satellites
that happen to be
in low Earth orbit.
If the densities get high
enough, it can cause charging
on the spacecraft, which I
don't think would damage it,
but could affect instruments
and the measurements
on those satellites.
I think that would be the
main effect in that case.
>> What is the relationship, if
there is one, between airglow
and the aurora borealis?
>> Sarah Jones: Sure.
Thank you, and I forgot
to repeat your question.
You were asking about
what would the effect
of the El Nino density in
the ionosphere have down here
on Earth, but your question
was: How are the aurora
and the airglow related?
Is that right?
Okay. Yeah, they are
related, actually,
because they're both very
similar chemical processes.
So the aurora happens when the
sun is giving off this steady
solar wind --
-- and magnetic field which
then impacts on the Earth.
Some of those particles leak
into the Earth's magnetic field
area and kind of get stuck there
and hang out there, and then
ionospheric particles also kind
of leak upward into that region,
and then during some
geomagnetic events,
like coronal mass ejections,
they can get accelerated
in a way that causes them to
cruise down the field lines,
kind of like in that
ionosphere video.
That's why you get the aurora in
a ring, because it's particles
that are traveling down
field lines from a region
where they got accelerated.
But what causes the line is
those particles coming down.
They impact the atmosphere,
knock electrons off
of the particles there.
That causes them sometimes to
give off light immediately.
Other times, you
get other light also
from when the particles
recombine,
and certain chemical
interactions give off certain
types of light.
So that's how it
works in the aurora.
In the airglow, it's
almost the same thing.
It's just sunlight
causing it to happen,
and so you also get
excitation, they call it,
where you get this
immediate release of light,
and then you also
get recombination,
especially at night, when
you're not getting bombarded
with sunlight anymore.
Those electrons and ions
kind of find their way back
to each other, and some of them
when they recombine
will give off light
in a variety of different
colors.
So it's very similar.
>> I think you mentioned the
GOLD satellite was a hosted
payload on another satellite.
What's the other satellite
for, and how do you build it
so that one doesn't
affect the other,
or do they affect each other?
>> Sarah Jones: Yeah,
that's a great question.
It's about the GOLD mission
being a hosted payload,
and how you avoid the one
mission affecting the other,
and what the primary
mission is for.
I actually don't know what SES
Government Solutions is using
SES-14 for.
I don't think it's
classified or anything.
I'm just not familiar with it.
I think it's a -- it
could be a TV satellite,
but that's speculation,
but we did go through a lot
of measures working with SES,
which is the parent company
of SES Government Solutions.
All along, actually from
even the proposal stage,
before the mission was selected,
the gold team was working
with SES, talking to them
about these exact things,
and how do we avoid affecting
each other adversely.
They wouldn't want us if we
were going to affect them,
and NASA wouldn't let us
launch if our data were going
to be affected, and so it's just
this long-term collaboration,
essentially, which
worked out quite well.
>> The surface of the
Earth is moving roughly
about a thousand miles per hour.
Is there a defining point
where the atmosphere relative
to space slows to zero
or so many feet per
minute or miles per hour?
And then of course, you
know, space is zero.
>> Sarah Jones: Yeah,
so essentially,
getting out of the
Earth's atmosphere depends
on reaching an escape
velocity, right,
so that your velocity
is actually faster
than gravity can pull you down
toward the Earth, essentially,
to keep you up out of there.
In terms of -- and the question
was about the atmosphere
as it becomes space and
that boundary there.
Is there a defining point
where the particles stop moving
with the Earth, essentially?
Yeah, I think that
the answer would be
that the particles
fall off gradually,
and where the point is that
they become space I think is
something that we
haven't really measured.
I'm not sure if they're --
they're probably our
models that would say,
but that actually would
be dependent a little bit
on the expansion of
the atmosphere due
to the energy coming
from the sun.
>> And a follow-up.
Is there any stripping
of our atmosphere
over the course,
ever, at any point?
I know with ozone, the hole
in the ozone at some point,
but is there stripping
because of that movement?
>> Sarah Jones: Yeah.
The question is: Is there a sort
of stripping effect
of the atmosphere?
And I think that's a really
great and interesting question,
because I think on other
planets in our solar system,
that's the understanding, right,
is that they may have had
atmospheres in the past
that were stripped away.
This is not my area
of expertise at all,
but I am really interested in
it, and I think that the idea is
that certain types of gas
could have been stripped away
in the past, but you'd have
to ask someone more expert
than me, but thank you.
>> On the slide up there,
it says the satellite
and the rocket on June 6th were
in California, and on June 14th,
they're going to be
up in the Pacific.
How do you get the
rocket up there?
>> Sarah Jones: Yeah, and thank
you for pointing this out,
because I poorly made
this slide, actually.
>> June 6th was yesterday.
>> Sarah Jones: This picture
is from May 22nd, 2018.
At that point, the satellite
and the rocket were
all in California.
Yesterday they did their
mission readiness review,
and I don't know when it
happens, to be honest,
but I do know that what happens
is that they take the rocket,
and the satellite, and
everything all put together.
They ferry it out to the
Marshall Islands shortly before
launch on June 14th.
>> On a ship?
>> Sarah Jones: I
think so, yeah.
>> Stephanie Marcus: I was
also interested in that,
in the type of launch where
it's going to be an airplane
with the rocket and
the satellite.
Why do they use the airplane?
Normally they would just
use the rocket for that.
>> Sarah Jones: That's
right, I think, and again,
it's not my expertise why
ICON is being launched
on this Pegasus rocket which
launches from an airplane.
They actually take off
with the airplane first.
But I believe it's because
you need less thrust
and propulsion once
you're already in the air
above the densest part
of the atmosphere,
and so that makes it easier
to get it up into orbit.
>> Stephanie Marcus: Okay.
That should be interesting.
>> What's the benefit from
launching it all the way
out in the Pacific versus
Vandenberg or anywhere else?
>> Sarah Jones: I know it was --
>> Stephanie Marcus: Question.
>> Sarah Jones: -- something
that had to be discussed.
Why would you choose to launch
from Marshall Islands instead
of somewhere like
Vandenberg or Kennedy?
I believe that the reason was
because the Marshall Islands
gave them the inclination
that they wanted for the orbit.
So it's something like a 20 or
22-degree inclination orbit,
which allows it to get
up around the tropics
and also measure
near the equator.
I think that was the reason.
>> Wasn't it fairly recently
that the charged particles
in the airglow were
photographed,
like within the past
20 years or something?
>> Sarah Jones: So the question
is, "How long has it been
since we started measuring
the charged particles
in the airglow?"
>> Yeah, I just remember
seeing like a photograph.
It was like a discovery, and
everybody was excited about it.
>> Sarah Jones: Oh, yeah.
I think I know what you mean.
One of the satellites that was
able to measure the aurora,
both regions and all
of the airglow at once.
It was the first time.
It was done very recently.
I'm sorry.
I don't remember what
mission that was, but in terms
of just measuring the airglow,
it's actually been
something that's been done
since the beginning of
this research field.
Also measuring the aurora.
And it's an interesting
question,
because we can use
the upper atmosphere
as a real laboratory
for chemistry.
Actually, there were chemical
emissions in the aurora
and airglow that had
never been seen on Earth,
and so there were big
debates about, "What is this?
What is the light coming from?"
We know it's coming
from a chemical reaction
between the particles, but
there were even speculations
about new elements
in the periodic table
that might give off this kind
of light, and the reason was
because some of these lines come
from metastable states, which,
at least at that time
and the level of vacuum
that they could achieve in
their laboratory experiments,
they would never see in the lab.
So the red line that happens
in the aurora and the airglow,
the particle receives the energy
and just kind of is metastable,
so it hangs out for like an
entire minute before giving off
light, and unless you're
at a really low density,
before that minute is up,
you're going to get hit
by some other particle, and
it's going to lose energy
that way instead of
giving off the red light.
So yeah, it's been
this really great way
of studying basic chemistry.
>> Stephanie Marcus: Have
we exhausted the questions?
Well, thank you all for coming,
and we'll see you in September.
We have a little hiatus
before our next lecture.
So thanks again for coming.
It's great to be here.
>> Sarah Jones: Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.